[Musique]
après 40 années passées sur scène le
chanteur Francis Lalanne qui a ses
dernières années tenues des propos
controversés sur la crise sanitaire à
surpris de nombreux Français en
annonçant monter sur les planches aux
côtés de Dieudonné
dans le cirque de mon ami Dieudonné
l'annonce d'un spectacle en duo avec
l'humoriste condamné à de multiples
reprises pour ses propos avaient alors
fait grincer des dents
et alors que ce spectacle devait avoir
lieu au Cirque d'hiver mais qu'il a été
annulé par les propriétaires Francis
Lalanne et Dieudonné viennent de trouver
une nouvelle salle le Zénith de Paris
s'il promet d'être vigilant le Zénith
affirme ne pas être en mesure
d'interdire cette représentation et qui
devrait avoir lieu en septembre prochain
nous nous disposons d'aucun élément qui
nous permettrait de penser que ce
dernier puisse être juridiquement
répréhensible alors trouvez-vous ça
normal
alors est-ce que oui oui bon alors
d'abord c'est pas du tout sûr que le
spectacle est mieux le Zénith a fait un
communiqué en s'en remettant aux
autorités de tutelle aux autorités
préfectorales en disant nous on est
obligé de les admettre sinon c'est du
refus de vente bien sûr il est très
possible que ce soit interdit comme
avait été interdit un spectacle de
Dieudonné à Nantes je crois en 2014 pour
risque de trouble à l'ordre public donc
là le préfet de police a maintenant la
balle entre ses mains et c'est pas du
tout sûr que ce spectacle est mieux
parce que effectivement ils craignent de
vrais troubles et de vrais problèmes est
dans le camp du préfet de police
absolument c'est au préfet de police de
décider et c'est pas du tout sûr qu'il
donne son avalé quand vous dites que la
balle est dans le Yama de donc ils ont
et la balle dans la main du préfet de
police qui est venu ici et absolument
donc c'est lui qui va décider si le
spectacle se fera ou pas exactement oui
non moi ça me choque pas ce spectacle il
impose à personne les gens qui ont envie
de le voir ils iront le voir les gens
qui ont pas envie ils prennent pas leur
billet c'est pas comme si on le
diffusait à la télé et que le spectateur
était passif est recevait ce spectacle
et ensuite le Zénith aussi il précise
que dans le communiqué qu'ils ont fait
qu'ils ont vérifié le spectacle et a
priori il y aurait pas d'incitation à la
haine il y aurait pas de trou alors de
public donc ce serait un spectacle entre
guillemets diffusable présentable et
dorétion donc ça va donc là ils ont le
droit de le faire ces deux artistes
après tout s'ils ont envie de le fasse
oui bonsoir merci je peux parler bien
sûr vous êtes ça dit que c'était très
intelligent ce que tu allais dire parce
que j'ai une théorie là-dessus et
vraiment partager il y a pas longtemps
il y a de Dieudonné a fait des excuses
au peuple juif son avocat est venu et a
dit pour qui excuse il faut qu'il
réparation donc il va donner de l'argent
je sais pas de synagogues au peuple juif
tout ça on n'a rien vu de tout ça il est
parti en Afrique soi-disant sur la terre
de ses ancêtres lui ne dit pas un mot
sur la réparation donc il s'excuse est
terminé comme par hasard derrière il
fait un spectacle donc il y a eu le buzz
des excuses et derrière il fait un
spectacle je trouve que tout ça il y a
ça sent un peu le je fais l'excuse je
fais du buzz on parle de lui et derrière
il y a un Zénith moi j'aurais aimé que
ça me fait douter sur les excuses je
porte je pense que tout ça est énorme
coup de com je pense qu'il aurait dû
déjà effectivement qui est réparation
montrer plus d'excuses sur le peuple
juif et là je trouve que il y a un
espèce de truc de comme qui me dérange
énormément la LED d'excuse on l'entend
plus et le Zénith
non je pense que je pense que moi les
excuses elles me semblait sincère et je
pense que voilà s'ils ont envie de faire
un spectacle ils ont le droit de le
faire on a le droit d'aller les voir et
il y a pas de tu vois pas de lianes
causalité entre le Zénith alors que
normalement il fait la Main d'Or les
excuses il y a encore des spectacles qui
ont encore besoin de ça je pense on a le
droit de croire que c'était sincère
Francis
ne leur ai pas accepté tu le sais ça il
jouait pas les spectacles
des pas de bêtises c'est les mérites
honnêtement moi je vous dérange non
jamais vous vous êtes toujours le
bienvenus à la maison
moi j'ai du mal avec les deux
personnages donc effectivement on peut
pas empêcher le spectacle on peut
empêcher les gens d'y aller mais
honnêtement il y a un moment il faut
être un peu descend et je te revois pas
du tout il a raison Mathieu les excuses
de Dieudonné sur le peuple Juifs
excusez-moi elles sont très relatives
elles sont voilà c'est c'est ça me gêne
énormément c'est plutôt l'attelage des
deux artistes qui est bizarre je trouve
parce que je pense pas que les fans de
Dieudonné et forcément dans le temps de
chantons de la neige la lame chantée et
les fans de la lande ont envie de
écouter les blagues de Dieudonné
un spectacle d'humour ensemble
pas du tout anglais
bien sûr artistiquement d'autres les
excuses de Dieudonné le courant quelque
chose en fait
il dit on peut pas atterrir un spectacle
on peut merci c'est ce que j'ai dit non
le Zénith ne peut pas faire du refus de
vente mais excusez-moi Dieudonné est un
personnage plus que sulfureux multi
condamné on peut se poser la question il
a déjà été interdit moi ce spectacle me
gêne
n'oublions pas également que les Zéniths
ont été construits avec de l'argent
public ce sont des équipements publics
même si après les spectacles c'est du
domaine de privé donc moi je suis désolé
juste un petit truc c'est que souvent la
technique de l'interdiction du spectacle
elle est pas bonne parce que derrière
qui se refont exactement ça remplit des
pages de journaux alors que ça aurait
fait trois lignes il passe devant le
tribunal le tribunal casse est plutôt
que de remplir un Zénith ils en
remplissent deux il a fait que la Main
d'Or quasiment oui mais c'est toujours
la technique du de s'il y a rien dedans
en tout cas c'est est-ce que tu dis s'il
y a des gens excuses les mairies ou tout
ça les préfectures auraient laissé le
spectacle au zénith mais c'est un Zénith
les mairies n'ont rien à voir là-dedans
on peut interdire tu es d'accord ou pas
alors non le truc je pense que ça va
leur faire du buzz je suis d'accord et
moi je suis d'accord avec Coco c'est que
le problème c'est que là moi je pense
que Zénith pourra pas interdire après
normalement envoyer le texte du
spectacle
et ils vont dire le problème c'est que
si on parle toujours de troubles alors
de public et qu'ils ont peur mais dans
ce cas là aujourd'hui il faut plus qu'il
y ait un ministre qui sort parce qu'il y
a trouble à l'ordre public parce que ça
crée des manifestations ça crée des gens
qui peuvent se battre donc moi je trouve
qu'interdire n'a jamais été
je vous rappelle je ramène pas ça du
tout à moi vrai vraiment jure que non je
vous rappelle que Bilal a arrêté son
spectacle dans une église parce qu'on a
eu peur qu'il y a trop peur de public
mais eux en revanche
parce qu'il a eu des menaces celui qui
l'a lui devant Jenny tu peux y avoir des
racines des machins des maisons ce que
tu veux on en a rien à [__] c'est pas
ça c'est que il y en a eux ils iront
jusqu'au bout parce que c'est leur
spectacle que Bilal il a décidé de
lui-même de l'arrêter oui pour pas qu'il
trouve leur public
et soutenu par certaines marques connues
et je suis pas sûr que les marques
aimeraient être associées aussi aux
propos de ou de Dieudonné ou de la lave
bon après c'est comme ils ont dit
c'est du refus de vente donc ils vont
ils servaient de compliqué pour eux
juridiquement on va on verra ça